hello everyone and welcome to a game
that I played like an hour and a half
ago and sorry about no videos yesterday
I'm playing the tournament it's being
played in my hometown and also yesterday
I had to go at the zagreb capital of
Croatia and my friend had a birthday so
I didn't get a chance to do any videos
but yeah I didn't prepare any videos for
today either so I decided just to show
you one of the games I played this is
the the sixth round of the tournament
and we're gonna have three more rounds
tomorrow so I'm playing against Marty
Auster which he's a freedom master from
neighboring town community some a very
strong player and I had the white pieces
against him so let's check it out I
opened with e4 as I usually do and he
replied with d6 the pills defense now
although you know people say a lot of
things about the pitch defense but the
fact of the matter is that today is
being played even on the highest level
even Magnus employs it from time to time
so I continue with d4 just grabbing the
center yeah he won 9 of 6 Knight c3 and
Knight B to d7 preparing d5 I developed
the Bishop Bishop to e3 with E 5
striking in the center and Knight to f3
just continuing development I thought
about instead of Knight to f3 now I may
be going for the for the f3 structure
but I didn't think that he would
actually Castle King Sarah I thought he
would just continue developing and if I
start pushing on the King said it he
would just Castle queenside so I decided
against it and I said okay we'll just
see what happens I had never actually
studied the pair it appears the defense
Bishop to e7
I played Bishop to c4 just putting my
bishop on a nice diagonal he castled i
castled and he played c6 now here i have
to be a little bit careful because b phi
will come with tempo and if if I allow
b5 he attacks the bishop I have to move
it next move he will play before attack
my knight and dislodge the defender of
the e4 pawn so he's just gonna be able
to snap it so Bishop to b3
just moving it back I don't have to
retreat with the bishop I could push a 4
also just maybe Bishop to d3 but I
decided
I want to keep my pawns where they are
and just keep the bishop on the long
diagonal so he continued with b5 and I
played a3 preventing b4 and here there
is one game where a five was played but
the he decided to go Bishop to b7 first
and it is as of mu9 that we have a
completely new game so I decided to
continue developing a plate Queen - e -
I want to get my looks into the game and
also yes I'm putting my queen and rook
on this awkward diagonal but I I decided
that there was no way to take advantage
of this he continued Queen to c7 also
developing the Queen connecting rooks
and I went look eight d1 he went a five
now b4 is definitely an idea and also
now if the bishop comes to a6 the rope
will be protecting it so I have to watch
out for Bishop to e6
if b4 comes then it comes with an attack
on the night and also on the Queen so I
have to prepare for this I play D
captures on e5 I'm not I'm not a fan of
breaking the tension in the center but
here I just didn't find a useful way to
continue the game so he played D
captures an e5 and now Bishop to g5 now
just getting rid of one of the attackers
of the e4 pawn and giving my my queen a
little more breathing space also
possible instead of Bishop g5 was just
Knights the age for going after the a
the v square which which would be nice
but then again just g6 i I have to go
back I decided against this so Bishop to
g5 this is what I played and he went
Knight the c5 here Bishop to e6 is
possible right away but then maybe maybe
you allow some real characters and d7
action where Knight will be unable to
capture as the bishop would Hank so
something like rook captures Queen
captures Knight captures here and of
course in black isn't better but it's
it's counter play you maybe don't want
to allow and yeah I mean I forgot to
mention the time control were playing 45
minutes plus 15 seconds increment so
after Bishop g5 he decided to go for a
knife to c5 puts pressure on the bishop
but his real plan is to remain over the
knight c6 to go after the d4 + f4 square
so I first captured an f6 we have Bishop
captures Bishop captures and not night
to d2 now my efore point is nicely
defended if even if he gets rid of one
of them and well next I can go either
develop the rook to e1 I can move the
Queen and avoid this Bishop to a6 threat
altogether so he played the ship to a6
and it is the best move recommended by
the engine and I went Queen to f3 now my
point the point is that if you if you
attack it now would be for yes you are
attacking the knight and you go after
the rook but I can just block both with
Nights 2 e 2 and here if if Trey's I can
trade and if he trades a knife or Bishop
I can just capture and I have a nice
open file for my rook so first he went
Knights the e6 and now I just decided to
trade it here so Bishop captures he
played F captures and now yes his pawns
are doubled but on the other hand he
will have a very strong pressure along
the F file also he will most definitely
Riemann over this bishop at the c5 from
where the EDF to pawn will be under
attack so here I've just I don't want to
allow b4 now if I don't have to so I
just played b4 to stop this plan
altogether and sort of he does have the
bishop pair which I really you know if I
can I prefer the bishop pair but here I
just didn't find a way to to avoid
trading my own bishop pair so he played
a captors I played a captors and he
played Bishop to e7 now opening up an
attack on the Queen and also on the B
for pawn I play the Queen to h3 I said
okay well we can trade b4 for the e6
pawn e6 pawn comes with check and he
makes the the correct decision he
doesn't guard d6 pawn he just captures
here he allows Queen captures on e6 with
check King to AJ and now he will
definitely have a very strong pressure
along the F file I played Knight seat to
be one just to getting getting the
knight out of harm's way he played the
ship back to c8 attacking my queen and I
went Queen back to b3 just moving the
Queen with tempo as the bishop is under
attack he went back to c5 also putting
pressure on the f2 pawn and now I went
Knight to f3
and here the material on the board is
equal the plus side for me is that I
have two points he has three points but
the bishop pair is that is extremely
strong here and I don't really have a
good way of deciding what to do with my
knight here probably something like
Knights the d2 and then seeing what
where to go from there
maybe move the Queen get a nice to be
three or something like that well he
played Bishop to g4 makes sense he wants
to bust open the Kings side also I
cannot move the knight as the look would
hang so rook the d3 just defending the
knight and here I think the the
situation on the clock was I had some
eighteen minutes and he had a little bit
less I think around fourteen and he
played Queen to e7 which is definitely a
good idea my plan here is if he does
like nothing if he makes a slow move
maybe I can go Queen to c3 or Queen B to
and go after the e5 pawn so maybe maybe
force him to trade on f3 and allow this
rook captures on f3 but he played Queen
to e7 his his idea is that if I make a
slow move let's say something like h3
then he goes Bishop to e6 attacks my
queen and after I moved the Queen like
the Queen c3 go after the pawn now he
just goes b4 pushes pushes the Queen
back and after I move the Queen best
best is just to capture on e5 then
Bishop to c4 wins wins d exchange here
so let's say Queen captures Bishop
captures and now well you do have to
move the rook rook d7 you go after the
mission but he just captures on f1 and
now it doesn't matter what you do if you
capture here he just captures here it's
not a problem if King captures on f1
then he just defends the bishop and he's
up the exchange I'm up a pawn but still
he's up the exchange not much you can do
here and after Bishop captures an f1 if
he goes for our rook captures if I go
root chakras and e7 instead he just
moves the bishop and again it's just a
much better position
rook is coming to a one that's there
there's not much I can do so after this
Queen t7 move I wasn't just about to
allow this Bishop e6 the c-4 maneuver I
played Queen to c3 right away just going
after that II five pawn but the
doesn't really work so feel free to
pause the video and try to figure out
what what Marty I played that really
complicated things for me while I give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations on finding such a such a
unique move and for those of you who
just want to enjoy so here he played b4
and here basically he said yeah you
can't capture here and well I don't
really have a good square for my Queen
if I move the Queen lets the Queen b3
again Bishop to e6 2 c4 it's the same
idea and well there's there's just not
much to do I mean but probably going for
this is the best and you know just
suffer now being the exchange down but I
decided to capture it either way I
played Queen captures he played Queen
captures I played Knight captures on e5
and now he gets this one Bishop to e2
and again one of my one of my rooks will
fall so I was a for the entire game I
was trying to keep my to keep my rook on
f1 away from his light square bishop but
the light square Bishop finds the way so
yeah even though it's not you know from
a6 or it's not this maneuver but you
know it's it's g42 so now my rook is hit
and I don't have a good move here I have
to allow him to grab the exchange so I
try to complicate things a little bit
more with rook to h3 but it doesn't work
everything is perfectly placed he just
played Bishop captures an f1 I played an
IG 6 with Czech he has to move the King
due to the pinned I so King to g8 I
played Knight captures an f8 and here he
just played Bishop to c4 and it was in
this position I moved 31 that I resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here my knight is under attack so I
either lose a piece or if I decide to
save the piece with 97 it even comes
with an attack on the bishop but it
doesn't matter since he has rook to a-1
and here it's just all over and Bishop
to c4 of course guards the B 3 square so
I don't have Luke to b3 so that that's
it that's again from round 6 that my
opponent won one
in a very nice way so here at after he
played Queen to e7 prepared this Bishop
to e6 what I should have done is
actually just Knight bTW - and here the
the threat is eliminated because now
after let's say Bishop to e6 if he
continues in this fashion then then I do
have Quintus e3 and the knight prevents
the Bishop from coming to c4 and if he
doesn't of course if not B to d2 III
just have to try and consolidate he's
still better I mean not not materialise
what he does have to - repair he
controls more space but if I if I get h3
and if I can maybe force a trade here
and and get my f1 rook into the game
it's still a game so yeah I was I was I
was very happy with how I played didn't
didn't really enjoy all that much
playing against the bishop pair and it
was a bit of a bit of a passive passive
approach against the peers but at least
now I will have some ideas on what
what's the studying when when going
against the peers and and will be able
to prepare myself a little bit better
for next time
so yeah here Knight bTW - would have
been better but like I said Queen to c3
and ended the rest is history so like I
said three more rounds tomorrow I will
try to either show one of the games from
tomorrow or if maybe we finish a little
bit faster maybe I will have time to to
finally start the the Morphy saga if if
not we will at some point where they
have so far I'm on three I think three
and a half out of six three wins two
losses and one draw so pretty decent as
my opponents were pretty much higher
rated than myself I even want some
twenty rating points maybe some a little
bit less than that but if I do well
tomorrow then it is going to be great
but yeah congratulations once again to
my opponent it was it was a really
interesting game and as you can see even
though you know people say a lot a lot
of things about the pits
it can actually be are usable opening
you know for every tournament
so that's the game I do hope you enjoyed
it I actually enjoyed it even though I
lost I would like to thank Gordon
Goodman Z temp Morgan during a Renata
mercurial and Dominic deja for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon with with whatever I can I can
do you know if I manage manage my time
well and I forgot to mention
mati is currently on 6 or 6 so he is
doing a really excellent this tournament
so yeah I think I will see soon and have
an excellent rest of your day